[Musique]
voir les enfants au froid
je suis content je suis content d'avoir
retrouvé mes petits amis et comment te
sens-tu ce soir nounours super peux pas
trop je suis curry sans je suis pas
[Musique]
oui on va
partir à plus jamais chez son cousin ce
que j'ai entendu
[Musique]
alors
oui ou non
je meurs de faim moi j'ai pas mangé
[Musique]
donnez-moi que langues-de-chat que vous
m'avez préparé
bon
que tu vas encore te faire un beau
cadeau
est-ce que tu aimes le plus elle est
pour toi la plus gros
[Musique]
des grands viens on va se coucher
vous êtes trop gentil je remonte vite
montrer chez beau cadeau au marchand de
sable bonne nuit le petit
bonne nuit maman à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours tes petits amis t'ont
fait des cadeaux
patron
[Musique]
j'ai du bon tabac
mais tu comptes
[Musique]
je comprends bien nounours je ne suis
pas ton ami mon patron seulement dans la
vous voulez du papa mais tu sais bien
que je ne fume pas de No et moi non plus
pas trop en route bonne nuit les enfants
[Musique]